I just realized that when I just
did problem number 14, I
got a weird answer because,
once again, I
cannot add and multiply.
But just redoing it just so
you get the right answer.
Number 14.
Oh, they give you a,
3a, dot, dot, dot.
And they say that each term is
3 times the previous term.
So the next term is going
to be 9a and so forth.
They say the sum of the first
five terms is 605.
And so what is a?
Well, what are the
first five terms?
It's a, 3a, 9a, 27a-- I'm just
multiplying by 3 every time.
81a.
And this is always the part
that I will mess up.
This is 1a.
So 1 plus 3 is 4.
4 plus 9 is 13.
13 plus 7 is 20, plus 1 is 21.
And then 4 plus 8, 121a is equal
to-- and they say, it
equals 605.
The sum of the first
five terms, 605.
a is equal to 605/121,
and that is 5.
Much easier when you
can add properly.
That's all I had for this video
because I just had to
correct my mistake.
See you in the next problem.